I Troy how are you I'm doing great how
are you better than I deserve what's up
so seven years ago I got turned on to
your system and at that point I was you
know over $70,000 in credit card debt
and didn't really have a clue what I was
doing and so I went out and got three
jobs and just started working working
like crazy and seven years later we
basically I have a corporation I own
have over 40 employees well we just
purchased our second commercial property
in downtown San Jose so great five
million dollars in commercial property
and ended by a nice million dollar house
in in the Bay Area which is basically a
small tract home but my meant my mind is
still the nervousness about money and
spending so I'm wondering at what point
you know I've already do the full max or
retirement I've already do the 10% to my
church but at what point are you able to
enjoy your hard work I still drive my
200,000 mile car and and I don't like
spending money on non necessities right
now
now what's your household income sir um
I make a little under 400 okay um well
you're enjoying your choosing to not
enjoy money as a choice it's not a
mathematical fact you make a ton of
money you're killing it you've gotten
yourself cleaned up
you got your funding your 401k you've
got your emergency fund in place I don't
hear anything is a dangerous on here you
make 400 K go buy yourself a freakin car
man take your wife on cruise yeah well
my wife has the nice $70,000 car but for
me I just I can't spend money on myself
okay let me ask you this how much money
are you giving what's your generosity
look like um well through my business
and personal I give about a half a
million dollars a year okay so the four
hundred thousand is after that occurs is
that what you're telling me yeah we we
did we did about 10 million this year so
we did four hundred thousand how
not engaged are you in the things that
you're giving to are you just write a
check and step on back oh you got your
hands on it um no I have my hands and
giving in and funding schools in South
America and stuff okay because usually
when you your generosity kicks up it
kind of gives you permission to enjoy
the money that's why I was suggesting
that but it sounds like that hasn't
worked yeah I mean I we we we do trust
me it's been a blessing but it I just
know that as easy is it no let me ask
you this okay let's talk let's talk
about this that you're let's talk let's
walk through some math for a second
you're giving away a half-million
dollars you're making four hundred
thousand do you think whether you drive
a $20,000 or fifty thousand dollar car
or a three thousand dollar car actually
matters in this math no it doesn't it's
irrelevant so you're really not
accomplishing anything by this it's not
like you're being conservative so that
you're safe dude you got other stuff
it's going to take you down long before
a car price takes you down right yeah I
mean so those commercial buildings as an
example would have been that would have
been something to be more concerned
about but I mean you know it was when we
pulled the trigger a well it's scary
I mean you buy five million dollar
building but you can't buy forty
thousand our cars so I mean if this is
just mental for you it really is it's
okay it's okay but I just want to give
you permission to enjoy it a percentage
of your money should be given a
percentage of your money should be
invested and a percentage of your money
should be enjoyed that's healthy good
financial management you're not proving
anything by driving a drunk car
especially at your stage dude you're
doing so well
congratulations your great American
success story man you're a hero this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
I want to write a song I want to own my
own business
I want to make more money those aren't
goals those are wishes my New Year's
resolution is to make more money this
year to wish